la météo les a motivé ce dimanche 28
février au matin ces sportifs amateurs
ont ressorti leurs raquettes pour faire
une heure de tennis entre amis au club
de plaisir ses licenciés ont réservé un
court extérieur sous un soleil quasi
printanier
bon j'adore c'est un peu compliqué quand
il pleut cantinage donc oui je vais
effectivement le beau temps nous incite
à les joindre petit peu dur moralement
ça fait un bien énorme
ça fait un bien énorme oralement et
c'est vrai que ça nous redonne un peu
d'énergie un peu de de plaisir parce
qu'il n'a pas beaucoup effectivement
souvent dans la société
c'est excellent là ça fait un bien fou
prend le soleil donc on est on est très
bien on peut pas rêver mieux là c'est
clair ce dimanche matin le tennis club
affiche complet avec des joueurs sur les
cinq courts extérieurs ces terrains sont
les seuls autorisés à la pratique
sportive en ce moment avec la crise
sanitaire
ce taux de remplissage exceptionnel du
week-end est donc rendue possible grâce
aux conditions climatiques de ces
derniers jours
une première depuis de longues semaines
vous savez moi je suis un président
heureux quand je vois les cours qui sont
tous occupés ou quand je vois mes école
qui fonctionne à plein rendement
quand quand on fait des compétitions que
ce soit les interclubs jeunes ou adultes
etc
c'est la vie d'un club mais cette vie a
complètement pratiquement disparu alors
on essaie de compenser en faisant quand
même de temps j'entends dès que le temps
le permet des animations à l'extérieur
on en fait de plus en plus au printemps
le tennis-club de plaisir pour
accueillir encore plus de joueurs en
extérieur les différents courts de terre
battue seront bientôt de nouveau
praticable
après les gelées de l'hiver jouer